we need two political parties in this
country
that are both living in reality and you
any one of them
it's a catch-22 basically side with
democrats or you're unpatriotic is the
line
either way you go democrats are going to
claim that republicans are in favor of
january 6.
democrats are jumping on this and saying
it sounds like republicans are afraid of
the truth
well it seems like democrats are afraid
of the truth that they don't want to
have a broader commission based on blm
we can play this game all day long
basically if you don't want an
investigation of an issue because you're
afraid it's going to get politicized
then we can just claim that apparently
you're afraid of the truth here is nancy
pelosi clicking and clacking her way
through this one
it sounds like they're afraid of the
truth and that's most unfortunate
but hopefully they'll get used to the
idea that the american people
want us to find the truth and that is
what we
intend to do and to do it in a way that
is as unifying as possible
that's why we yielded unifying as
possible if i wanted to go to another
committee i would have done it sooner
but i didn't want to go there
no what you wanted to do is get a little
bit of cover from people like john catko
so that she could pretend that it was a
bipartisan commission after making it
not bipartisan because the entire
staffing process
is controlled by democrats again you
could have had an impeachment inquiry
you did you impeached trump on this
inside of a week because it was just so
urgent to get rid of trump
before he left office like a week later
and then you held it up
for several days before even submitting
it to the senate so this is politics
all the way down and nancy pelosi
pretending to stand on principle is one
of the most ridiculous things in life
here's chuck schumer doing the same
thing
letting the most dishonest president in
american history
dictate the prerogatives of the
republican party will be
its demise mark my words
whatever that means for democrats it's
bad
for america we know we all know
there needs to be a thorough and honest
accounting of what took place on january
6th
the greatest attempted insurrection
since the civil war
okay the greatest attempted insurrection
since the civil war uh no
i mean really no the greatest attempt we
literally had two billion dollars in
property damage over the summer with
people who wanted to destroy the systems
of the united states we had federal
buildings attacked on mass
it's not even the greatest insurrection
attempt to the last 18 months
okay it was it was evil and it was
egregious and the images were
horrifying and the criminals should go
to jail it was a bunch of morons who
went into the capitol building were
promptly
dispersed and arrested within like five
hours and then the entire system just
went on as before so
no no but but again the goal here is not
real it's not about january 6th
and what this is really about is
democrats attempting to prolong
the incident of january 6th and raise
that as the specter and then suggest
that all republicans are in defense of
that
and so they created this catch-22 for
republicans either they go along with
this very biased commission that is
designed to elicit a response saying
that all republicans are responsible for
january 6th
or republicans say we're not going to go
along with that commission and then
democrats say well see they won't go
along with commission
because they're in favor of january 6.
so either way you go democrats are going
to claim that republicans are in favor
of january 6th meanwhile democrats
who are running for senate have decided
to make a big issue out of this of
course tim ryan democrat of ohio who
ran a very short-lived ill-fated
presidential campaign last time around
and now wants to run for senate in ohio
because
of course rob portman's seat is open he
uh he decided the best strategy would be
to get up and shout a lot and the media
would pay attention to him
ben gods that you guys chased the former
secretary of state
all over the country spent millions of
dollars
we have people scaling the capital
hitting the capitol police with lead
pipes across the head
and we can't get bipartisanship what
else has to happen in this country
cops this is a slap in the face to every
rank and file cop
in the united states if we're going to
take on china
if we're going to rebuild the country if
we're going to reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you any one of them okay uh just a
couple of questions on that particular
clip one
when he says that if we want to fight
climate change then we need to do the
january 6 commission i'm confused as to
how these two are related
when he starts ranting and raving about
how its disrespect to cops not to do
january 6 commission
this is coming from the same party that
has been ripping on the police as
systemically racist
for well over a year minimum i mean
actually
longer than that going all the way back
to the obama administration and cops are
quitting on mass so
you've picked an odd example of things
that are disrespectful
to the cops the media are trying to play
that aspect of this up of course they
did this a little bit falsely
yesterday there's a letter yesterday it
was released by
basically an unknown number of anonymous
capital police officers and the media
played it up as though the actual u.s
capitol police had sent out a letter
calling for the january 6th commission
the u.s capitol police immediately
denied that and said that is not correct
but not before nancy pelosi
and members of the media like olivia
beavers decided that they would pump
out the news that the u.s capitol police
had called explicitly
for an investigation in january 6th
commission
later olivia beaver's this this reporter
she had to actually walk that back she'd
delete her tweet her original tweet
had something like six thousand retweets
and twelve thousand likes and it was
replaced with the tweet saying oh yeah
no it was just a couple of
anonymous capital police officers who
said they wanted a january sixth
commission
that tweet had like 33 likes because
that's the way things work on twitter if
it's if it's
information that confirms your priors it
goes viral if it's information that does
not confirm your priors
it does not meanwhile cnn playing up
exactly the democratic party line here
that is republicans
are choosing party over country that was
literally the chiron on cnn
which is pretty strong editorializing
here from cnn
now we know what republican house
leaders will do when confronted with a
domestic terror attack on our capital
nothing it's the most cynical and
spineless act
imaginable it's the definition of
putting party
over country because of opposing a
bipartisan commission to investigate the
insurrection on january 6
republican minority leader kevin
mccarthy is once again
choosing trump over the truth while
carving out his own profile and
cowardice
don't worry guys this is all just
journalism it's all just journalism
again the entire january 6th commission
theory here
is not that they want to get to the
bottom of the systemic law enforcement
failures the bottom line here is that
what they wish to do
is castigate everybody who disagrees
with them politically and then lump them
in
with january 6th and again it's just set
up for a catch-22 the catch-22
is that you're unpatriotic if you are
against the january 6th the commission
you're in favor of january 6th if you're
against the january 6th commission as
constructed by the democrats even if you
offer an alternative
and also if you go along with the
commission and then that bias commission
comes up with a report
saying that every republican was
complicit in january 6 which of course
has been the democratic party line
since the day of january 6th if you do
that
then of course you're also unpatriotic
so it's a catch-22 basically side with
democrats or you're unpatriotic
is the line and this holds true
throughout american public life
the the new rule from the media the new
rule from democrats is that if you side
with democrats you're patriotic and if
you don't side with democrats you are
unpatriotic and that
holds true for every radical theory they
push forward
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content